يعد مجلس الوزراء الذي يختار من قبل الحزب
الفائز بالانتخابات وحلفائه اوسع تشكيل
لاتخاذ القرار في اسرائيل وتضم الحكومه
الحاليه 38 وزيرا وهي اكبر حكومه في تاريخ
اسرائيل ينبثق عنها مجلس وزاري مصغر
للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه ويطلق عليه
الكابينت ويتم اختيار اعضائه بعد تنصيب
الحكومه وهو مختص ببحث قضايا هامه وحساسه
على الصعيدين السياسي والعسكري اضافه الى
قرارات السلم والحرب ويضم المجلس الوزاري
المصغر الحالي 14 وزيرا من بينهم الوزيران
عن اليمين المتشدد اتمار بن كفير وبتسل
ايليس مترش حكومه الطوارئ تشكلت يوم
الحادي عشر من اكتوبر الماضي وهي الحكومه
الفعليه بعد انضمام حزب معسكر الدوله
بزعامه بن جانس الذي كان قبل الحرب على
غزه احد اقطاب المعارضه مجلس الحرب هو
اضيق تشكيل سياسي وامني في اسرائيل حاليا
وتشكل ايضا في الحادي عش من اكتوبر لاداره
شؤون الحرب ويضم كلا من رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع يواف جالانت
اضافه الى بني جانس كما يشارك فيه بصفه
مراقب قائد اركان الجيش السابق جادي
ايزنكوت ووزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه رون
درمر